♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
The CDC announced last week
that fully vaccinated Americans
no longer need to wear masks
in most indoor
or outdoor settings.
"Oh, my God, finally!",
said unvaccinated Americans.
After the CDC
announced it on Thursday
that vaccinated people no longer
need to wear face masks indoors,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
said that masks
will still be required
in the chamber.
And when Marjorie Taylor Greene
heard that,
she became so unhinged
that nobody noticed
any change in
her demeanor whatsoever.
According to
The New York Times,
President Biden
does not make quick decisions
and often asks for
detailed briefings and debates
from staffers
before making up his mind,
which is honestly refreshing,
considering the last guy
didn't always get
the wrapper off the burger.
According to a new poll,
only 52% of Americans
say they trust the CDC.
Reached for comment,
the CDC said, "Ask again later."
According to a new report
in The New York Times,
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
is a wine connoisseur.
Dr. Biden first
became interested in wine
the 38th time
she heard about Scranton.
"I'm just going to
top this off."
According to a new survey,
72% of Americans
think they could beat a rat
in a fight.
9% think they could beat
a crocodile.
And 6% think they could beat
a grizzly bear.
This news first reported
by the kid
you're trying to get to bed.
"I don't know.
Uh, I guess rat, yes.
Crocodile, maybe."
Researchers in Japan
recently found that mammals
that have been deprived
of air can be saved
by receiving oxygen
through their anuses.
While researchers deprived
of oxygen
come up with
some pretty wild stuff.
A 111-year-old man in Australia,
who is believed to be
the country's oldest-ever man,
said in a recent interview
that the secret to living a long
life is eating chicken brains.
Oh, I didn't even know you could
get Hot Pockets in Australia.
And, finally,
today was National Walnut Day.
Celebrate by ruining
some chocolate chip cookies.
♪♪
President Biden traveled
to Detroit today,
but only because someone
asked him about Israel.
[ As Biden ]
Whoops, I gotta go!
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke yesterday
with Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu
and called for a cease-fire
in the fight between Israel
and Hamas.
Oh, good,
if anyone can solve this,
it's definitely the guy
who can't control his own dog.
[ Laughter ]
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said today
he is opposed
to a 9/11-style commission
to investigate
the January 6th Capitol attack.
And, in similar news,
Derek doesn't want you
to look in his sock drawer,
especially way in the back.
[ Laughter ]
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
announced yesterday
that the state will lift
its social distancing mandates
this week
for fully vaccinated people.
Okay, but, you know that's not
why people are staying
away from you, right?
[ Laughter ]
Former New York Mayor
Rudy Giuliani's son
Andrew Giuliani announced his
run for New York governor today
and told reporters,
"It's in my DNA."
Also sharing Rudy's DNA --
his first wife.
[ Laughter ]
Former Trump administration
official Stephen Miller
has been accused
of trying to sabotage
New York mayoral candidate
Andrew Yang's campaign
by publicly endorsing him
in a series of tweets.
And Yang can sabotage
his own campaign with tweets,
thank you very much.
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
yesterday released
his 2020 tax returns,
though, keep in mind,
he loves to underreport things.
[ Laughter ]
South Carolina
Governor Henry McMaster
signed a bill into law yesterday
that requires death row inmates
to choose between the electric
chair or a firing squad.
Or there's always
the third option --
just pay the parking ticket.
[ Laughter ]
A Tesla car on autopilot
recently crashed
into a Washington State
deputy sheriff's patrol vehicle
and, now, the Tesla driver
[ As Johnny Carson ]
will likely face
a battery charge.
[ Laughter ]
Did you like that one, Wally,
"a battery charge"?
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
an anonymous resident
of an apartment in Australia
recently posted a message
in the building's elevator,
addressed "To the woman
[with] extremely loud orgasms."
[ Laughter ]
Can you imagine reading that
and thinking,
"Oh, no!
I sound like a woman?!"?
♪♪
President Biden today delivered
the commencement address
at the U.S. Coast Guard Academy.
The Coast Guard has changed
a lot since Biden was young,
but then again,
so have the coasts.
After House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy
came out in opposition yesterday
to a bipartisan agreement
to create
a 9/11-style commission
to investigate the January 6th
Capitol attack,
Democratic Caucus Chair
Hakeem Jeffries said,
"I don't know what
Kevin McCarthy is afraid of."
Oh, if I was going to guess,
I'd say ghosts, spiders, clowns,
lightning, dogs,
spicy food, fireworks,
and Donald Trump?
The House voted today
on legislation
to create
an independent commission
tasked with investigating
the January 6th attack
on the Capitol,
while House Republicans
are still claiming
that there was no January 6th
this year.
President Biden yesterday toured
Ford's electric vehicle facility
in advance of the company today
unveiling its new truck,
the Lightning.
So just try peeing on this one,
Calvin.
Several Republican lawmakers
on Tuesday
protested House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi's mask rules
on the floor
during a voting session.
And Representative Bryan Mast
said after
that the fine was the,
"best $500 I ever spent."
"Not me,"
said Matt Gaetz.
[ Laughter ]
"I got the Venmo receipt
to prove it."
The New York Attorney General's
Office announced yesterday
they are,
"actively investigating
the Trump Organization
in a criminal capacity."
"That's awful,"
said Ivanka...Jones.
A strip club in Las Vegas
will begin offering coronavirus
vaccinations later this week.
They'll have Moderna
and AstraZeneca,
but just know their real names
are Cynthia and Beth.
[ Laughter ]
A strip club in Las Vegas
will begin offering coronavirus
vaccinations this week.
Said dudes, "Am I crazy, or did
that nurse really like me?"
A strip club in Las Vegas
will begin offering coronavirus
vaccinations later this week.
But just remember,
they can vax you,
but you can't vax them.
The vacation rental company
booking.com
will offer fans
of the sitcom "Friends"
a chance to win
an overnight stay
in a replica of Monica's
New York City apartment.
So if you've always wanted
to spend the night
at Monica's apartment,
just tell her, man.
Mattel yesterday unveiled
a Helen Keller Barbie doll.
Still not as blind as Barbie.
How can you not see it?
Do you really believe
those are business trips
he takes every weekend?
And, finally,
a woman recently wrote
to the "Dear Prudence" advice
column in Slate magazine,
asking what to do about finding
her 12-year-old son
in a compromising position
with the vacuum cleaner.
Well, for starters,
change the bag.
♪♪
President Biden misspoke
earlier this week
during his visit to Michigan
and referred to his father,
who was a salesperson,
as a coal miner.
I'm sorry, but how the hell
do you mix those two up?
That's like saying,
"And my mom was a homemaker --
oh, wait, astronaut."
The White House said yesterday
that President Biden spoke
to Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu
and told him that the U.S.
"expected a significant
de-escalation
and a path to a cease-fire
with Hamas."
A path?
To a cease-fire?
You don't need a path.
Everything you have to do
is in the name.
"Cease-fire."
What else did he say?
[ Birds chirping ]
Let's end this thing, Bibi.
Now, I'm gonna count
to a million.
While discussing the ongoing
criminal investigation
into the Trump organization
in a new interview,
former President Trump's
ex-personal lawyer Michael Cohen
said that Trump will
flip on everyone,
including "his children."
Said Trump, "Alleged children."
Microsoft co-founder Bill Gates
made his first
public appearance yesterday
since his divorce announcement,
and I don't want to assume
how he's doing,
but, oh, my God, he got bangs.
[ Chuckles ]
According to a recent survey,
nearly 30% of Americans
are hesitant to invest
in Bitcoin
because they do not understand
cryptocurrency,
and another 30% are hesitant
to invest because they do.
Authorities in the UK
recently arrested two men
who were allegedly running
a marijuana distribution site
out of an abandoned Bingo hall.
Police became suspicious
when someone under 70 went
into a Bingo hall.
Drone companies
are reportedly preparing
to deliver coronavirus vaccines
to Americans
in rural communities.
Ah, yes -- nothing will increase
rural Americans' faith
in the vaccines
like having them delivered
by a corporate drone.
A new online game has launched
that challenges users
to try to spend all
of Tesla CEO Elon Musk's
$166 billion fortune
in 30 seconds.
"Done!" said someone getting
a six-pack of razors.
A zoo in Germany
announced yesterday
that its newest polar bear cub
is the product of breeding
between two polar bear siblings.
Wow, they really do treat
their animals like royalty.
According to a new study,
the average person
spends around $100 every month
on their pet.
It's what the cat charges.
"Look, I'm not gonna walk
over to you for free.
I hate you."
Authorities
in New Hampshire yesterday
charged a man
for allegedly detonating
80 pounds of explosives
at a gender reveal party.
Even scarier, soon he'll be
charged with raising a child.
And, finally,
according to a new study,
dating apps like Bumble,
Grindr, and Tinder
are in the top 15%
of battery-draining apps
on smartphones.
Even more draining --
the people you meet on them.
And that, you guys,
was the monologue.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]